hello and welcome to the Udacity course
on prototyping in this course we'll be
covering the fundamentals of making
prototypes to quickly and effectively
make choices about your app this is a
vital skill for entrepreneurs product
managers and anyone else who wants to
build an experience that will delight
users my name is Jay I'm a Udacity
instructor and I'll be guiding you
through the practical application of
these skills later parts of the course
will also feature Carl a UX engineer at
Google and Johnathan an envision
specialist they will be helping you with
the details of user research and medium
to high fidelity prototyping the art of
prototyping mainly exists to make your
apps better and save you time and money
when building products you like having
more time and money you should be
prototyping let's get started